The joe rogan experience. I'm going to
go out on a limb. Yeah, she looks up.
She looks good. I like it.
So, um, for 20, 20, I'll tell
you who's going to run. Okay.
Bernie's going to run again.
He is. Yes. How can he do that?
1,000 different sites to who's
going to run? He'll be 78 years old.
He's riding a fucking wave
though, man. Gh. I've been lifted.
I'm going to try to straighten my net.
Go.
I tried to pull it back up into the snow
position. I got one of those things.
It hangs from the door. I'm stretching
my neck. He's like Larry, Larry David,
right. It looks like Larry
David. Yeah. What about Oprah?
Oprah is not running bullshit.
She's not wrong. She's going to run.
I'm calling her right now. She'd not,
she's not wrong. She's running. Well,
that'd be fodder for us to laugh at
it for a long time. I don't know man.
She might win. No, she,
how about fucking NBC?
Whoever the Dork is that was running
the NBC Twitter that was saying our
president, like they about
Oprah. That, yeah, I'll know.
And Oprah gave that speech
that was at the Golden Globes.
She gave this big giant space and
everybody was like, she's got a vagina,
let her talk. And she, she's given
me listen, big powerful speech.
Hollywood is so fucking insular.
They love sniffing their own farts
and stuck in their own dick. Wow.
Clueless actress. Stacey Dash is
running for Congress in California.
Wait a minute. Stacey dash is like a
Republican. She's like a harlot. Big Time.
She was on Fox News. Trump supporter.
Republican. Yeah, she was. Oh, clueless.
The movie they meant to Sarah. Yeah,
she's clueless. I read it wrong.
Maybe she is clueless to, but Stacey
dash is like super hardcore. Oh yeah.
Super Hardcore Republican Fox commentator
known for a controversial opinions.
So Oprah, Oprah. No, not
right now. I'm telling you.
I'm telling you the Edmund's going to
be the first man. The Rock not running.
Mark Zuckerberg wants to run, but he might
not run. Why don't you think he'll run?
Is He old enough? Zealand? He's 34
he's old enough. But I'd be like,
get in under the wire. How fucking
goofy is that guy, man? I mean, oh,
how goofy is he?
He's goofy show.
He showed the picture of him like
fucking feeding a lamb or some shit.
He did an okay to fetal lamb.
What's wrong with this person?
I'm anti lamb feeding. I'm taking a
strong stance on the Joe Rogan bottom one,
wants lambs to starve to death.
The secular talk podcast.
Um, yeah, Mark Zuckerberg,
he's been like doing this goofy Toro
where he goes to Iowa and pretends to eat
with regular people and he's like,
I spoke to a guy named Ted today
and he has a interesting story. Hmm.
I hate the pandering where they try to,
that's the thing,
like when they bring up the
personal stories and they're
like pretending to care
about some random dude and
Kentucky, it's like, fuck off.
Just tell me what your ideas are. You
don't have to do the fake empathy shit.
Right, right, right. Uh, so I
don't think he's going to run,
even though he wants to because
he'll get his ass handed to him.
Mark Cuban is another guy with a
giant ego who thinking about it,
but I don't think he'll end up doing it.
I don't think they want that scrutiny.
Like yeah, a lot of shit comes out. Yeah.
I mean think about who Trump was
preelection and Trump is now before the
election was kind of lovable.
He's like this lovable Egomaniac
Weirdo guy he had for the election.
Yeah.
Well you know,
let me take that back cause there's was
all that birth or shit that was pretty
wacky but pre birth or shit,
he was the guy who played the role of the,
I'm the big boss. Corporate is
sky. Who was the guy with the,
I'm the duck date.
It was like a bigger than life character.
Large hair. Big fucking
name on the buildings. Gold,
gold lettering everywhere. Gold
bathroom, gold toilet paper.
Like he was just silly. Did he not know
that? Like there's such a thing as as,
what's the word I'm looking for?
Garish is that garrison.
I don't think he does know that well.
He's old man with old people.
That was like someone said it best and
it's one of my favorite quotes about
Trump that he is what a poor person
imagines. A rich person would be like.
That's a great point. Yeah, and he's a,
he's a dumb person's idea of a smart
person because he's very confident and he
most,
and like you say gold fucking everything.
It's almost like it's almost
like a wrappers or stuntin.
Oh yeah, I got my role as
bitch. Yeah, you got to Trump.
Is that Grill Paul Wall
style showing all your rings.
You're in front of your Lamborghini.
Bunch of girls shaking
their booty in front of you.
How did grills ever become a thing?
How did they not become a thing?
Why don't I have one?
That's a real question.
We were going to get what Paul wants.
People reached out to us.
We're going to hook us up. You could
actually maybe make grills popular.
I don't think so. I'm doing a
good job with fanny packs though.
I'm telling you that. Oh,
sales are up. Sales are up.
I'm pretty sure fanny packs are back.
You know what?
I haven't given up on cell phone
holder. I saw the post. Yeah,
I saw those people gave up on that a
long time ago and they'll make fun of me.
But I'm like fuck you. It's coming
back in style and I'm rocking it.
Somebody had a very funny joke.
I forget who it was.
I wish we could give them credit,
but it was something along the lines
of that's the type of black guy that's
unthreading to white people type of black
guy that wears the cell phone holder
or the outside is buckle
clip cell phone holders.
Just don't have him weird around a cop
because they might think it's a gun.
That's right. Don't reach for it.
Don't reach for anything. Um, yeah.
The um, the grill thing, I dunno. Um,
I think a gold tooth
be kinda fly like one,
like maybe a Fang or Fang. Cause I
think that they think it shows status,
but in reality it shows in attempt to
hit higher status. You know what I mean?
Well, it's like that Jay z song, 99
problems, but a bitch ain't one. You know,
if you grew up with hose
holes and use Zap Atos,
you'd celebrate the minute
you haven't doe. Right.
So we critics you can kiss
my whole asshole. So when
you don't grow up with much,
then you're like,
yeah,
I'm going to fucking get a lot and then
I'm going to show off that I have a lot.
So you know, I got this shit.
It's a giant part of the culture.
I mean and even in the more
reserved people like Nas,
like who's like a more lyrical artist type
character. Father was a jazz musician.
He drives a Mercedes and his
pictures in front of the nice things.
It's just a part of the whole culture.
Like you got to got to have nice shit.
He can't be living in a log
cabin spitting out rap music.
Nobody wants to hear that.
Like anybody from like a book.
What's that show life below the, the
show where they're all in Alaska, Alaska.
Nobody wants those people rapping.
But I feel like if somebody does that,
then that for that person, it really is
about the art of what they're doing. Yeah.
You know what I mean?
It's not going to happen.
No one's going to listen to a fisherman
rap like a dude who's like salmon
fishing commercial,
like one of those dudes from deadliest
catch. If one of those guys, hey, look,
when they're, you can't, can't
be a rapper. He smell like
fish. You got to be clean.
You have to have gold teeth or something.
You have to have a grill.
That's a is Paul Wall.
Okay.